till 3:00 and got to try and find your legs
early Robertson a one time Drive save made
by lingren the rebound on net and lingren
is able to take one away from pavelski as
well easier said than done though when you're
taking on the number three penalty kill team
in the NHL Dallas been a terrific team on
special team two shame between the legs in
on Charlie lingren and lingren another sharp
start makes this stop is it's a sharp angle is
Joel Edinson there's not a lot of room if you
get into his neighborhood M Michel sends it
deep wood keeps it moving not pass protus out
in front car's on there wetwood can't stop it
score it looked like a bank shot from trotus that
finds the net behind Wedgewood and the capitals
take the early lead by Scott Wedgewood behind the
net he fans on it and his stick actually hits the
end boards as he's trying to backhand this behind
the net prus gets to it first and as he throws it
out in front watch it deflect off of Wedgewood
who goes around the far side of the net I think
does this hit the dawn off first snaps a pass to
to lud hinan he keeps it on side pressure put on
by the Stars here sing on ni bler save is made
by lindr Steel back door off the outside the
Net score on the one t San he found the puck
on the goal line a beautiful find from steel
and the Dallas Stars are on the board to tie
it at once are all at even strength Sam Steel's
going to start this play and he goes across the
seam that seam opens up it's the the shift gets
long for the Caps look at that seam you can drive
a bus through there but steel finds Sean not much
room and re DK poked it away duaine puts it
right back into the Washington end Marksman
back to duchaine to the forehand sa made
with the blocker guided Away by lingren
and comes away with it tries to work his way
around Harley and with a step Anthony mantha
moves in R shot save made with the stick by
Wedgewood to donov is coming up possible odd
man Rush here for the Caps lobed ahead after
it's Tom Wilson gets to the goal line fires
one save made with the glove by Wedgewood he was
off balance but adjusted in Denver to meet the
Avalanche the Golan centering pass off the
outside of the net van D sets one up shot
score stro found the loose change his rer
Beats Wedgewood and Washington retakes the
lead Wilson and avkin and this Puck comes to
Wilson he wants to shoot it and he whips it
well he whips it look at Dylan stro happens
to be coming around the backside of the play
his shot will beat Wedgewood under the glove
it's his first goal in seven games for Dylan
strome he leads the caps with nine now he
could shoot the puck and there he is from
15 or 17 ft these next 10 or 12 minutes
are really important for Dallas here this
is when you can lose your legs on the back
to back but you don't want to lose contact
with the game break away for who's Nets
off to the backhand back to the forehand
score it's a TW goal lead for the Caps if get K
Nets off his fifth of the year it's gained 700
this is an outstanding play by Alexi protus
to come all the way back he lifts The Stick
of Matthew Shane Matthew Phillips throws it up to
ketov who's poaching at the far Blue Line telling
you there's not many guys would have the patience
or the courage to make this move not the first one
but the second one and Joe wall and taken over
oy cubel across the line two-on one with Carlson
WR shot whistles wide all the way out to the
neutral zone duaine he has Marchman set up that
shot score Marchman snaps it home off the feed
from duchaine and Dallas right back in it down by
one oey kubel to make on the two-on one as
he misses the net it basically becomes the
Dallas Stars breakout way up the ice Marchman
had to go get his stick he comes back into the
play and Matt duchaine in his 1,000th game
puts this right on the T and marchment fires
it up over Charlie lindgren's Shoulder Through
Center is keto across the line with some speed
R shot at h IR another shot by Jensen blocked
on the way in San at one end and then he's
robbed by Carlson at the other Harley that
shot glove save made by linden he flashes
leather again this is their first opportunity
of the night henan hoping for a passing Lane
now it's Robertson he shoots that carams in
on Net score tipped in front it looked like
may have gotten the piece but Power Play goal for
Dallas and they've tied the game and the double
stack in front hint is right in front Ben is out
in the slot and so lingren got to fight through
both goal both players Ben definitely deflects
this hints is standing right on the goal creas
I think this is going to be Ben's goal as
lingren can't get a second deflection on
it himself as it goes up in the air misses his
block he scored three goals and got in a fight
player oh that's get on net save the rebound
put on net as well loose and now a penalty
call chopped off the Stick of haena and moved out
to Ben possible two-on one Steel on his left to
Steel short-handed shoot save made by lingren
and a chance back the other way mantha across
the line mantha Sur strome P SC on the power play
stro Lights the left and Washington has the lead
back in tight the puck turns around
and Dylan stro is second tonight on
the power play this time under the glove
of Scott Wedgewood it's his 100th career
goal and off the Anthony man the feed the
Caps have the lead again he feeds him prota
shoots wide he went High TR the blocker
side of wedw and missed the net back the
other way pelski off to Robertson and now
hit shoots score fore hint ties it with 610
remaining he's missed that's the end of his shot
comes around Peli and as Robertson drives through
that backs up the defender and rupe hints is
on the board twice here in the third period he
beats lingren on the blocker shot pass through
the crease that was an intent and bringing it
back marksman to the back hand save made by
lingren as marman tried to roof one revers
to Lindell shot in front Jamie Ben stopped
by lingren he does the snow angel in the
crease Johnston with speed around
oetkin behind the net B about to
wrap around it's deed to Ben drops
it right back to Johnston Johnston
dangling shoot save made by lingren
tough rist shot into the corner back
to the point Carlson across oin again tries
one save made by Wedgewood and the clear by
Lindell ason Robertson one for
two in shootout opportunities
this season he'll try first for
Dallas the forehand scar low to
the stick side Robertson he's different
going in against the right hand catching
goenda to try and keep the game alive
for Washington to the back hand denied
Again by Wedgewood and the shootout
Victory goes to the Dallas Stars
see